Try out your updated app
if you haven't already.
You'll need to wait a while for the data
to show up in the Analytics dashboard.
But don't forget, you can always check
the logs to see if the hits got sent,
if your phone or
tablet is connected to Android Studio.
In the Analytics dashboard,
go to Conversions > Ecommerce >
Shopping Analysis > Shopping Behavior.
And make sure the date range
is set as you want it to be.
So, now we see that some of
the sessions include Check-Out,
let's confirm in
the Checkout Behavior page.
Drum roll please.
And we see that we had some sessions
with step one of Check-Out.
Step one implies maybe there's a step
two and actually there can be, and
I'm going to talk more
about Check-Out steps soon.
Also notice there are no transactions,
and
that's because a transaction
involves money changing hands.
Or more technically speaking,
a transaction requires a product
action to be action_purchase,
or action_refund.
We'll be getting to transactions next.